Prince Ali fabulous  show some respect  boy Jeff you flip down on one knee now  try your best to stay calm  brush up your Friday salon then come and  meet a spectacular  as long as ten breaking amendment  definitely means base together pink  Ward's a hundred bad guys with swords  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  you some other on an opportunity  I can make you rich rich enough to  impress a princess  what would I have to do there's a Cave  of Wonders  bring me the land  [Music]  oh great one who summons me I stand by  my oath loyalty to wishes 3mk rushed  [Music]  hey can you make me a prince there is a  lot of gray area in make me a prince I  could just make you a prince oh no you  look like a prince on the outside but I  didn't change anything on the inside  Showtime no I'm in charge okay I say  when it's done  [Music]  really  I thought a princess could go anywhere  not this princess do you trust me  [Music]  [Music]  you